[Music]
carnegie-mellon began its life as a
trade school we are studying the trade
or the craft of theatre design as a
specific exercise within the fields of
architecture and drama and seen a
graphic design I've learned a lot of
things from the drama students in
particular because they know so much
about the workings of theatres and it's
really added depth and complexity to my
projects which I appreciate so much
because that's not something that I
might have figured out by myself and
having that extra experience is really
nice because you not only get to make
new connections and your friends but you
also learn a lot from them I think that
interdisciplinary work really is the
future of design and working with all of
these different types of programs and
students from other departments is
really helping bring more information to
light and we can't do the project
ourselves obviously no one can so we
want to understand what performance
spaces of all types can be like how the
process of the design of such a facility
occurs the methodology through which the
different players not just the actors
themselves but the producers artistic
directors architects engineering firms
and most importantly ultimately the
audience who consumes this work I think
having some experience in the production
side of things is very it's very
knowledgeable asset to have in this
class it's really great to sort of
reflect on what my responsibility is and
what my role is as a theatre artist and
then to analyze that in relation to
others and then sort of saying okay this
is this is what how we can optimize this
this is the solution for this space this
is why we should do this and this
solution might not work just getting to
kind of see the site and look at other
theatres as reference and just visit
different architecture firms
definitely help me realize the
importance of things like researching
your site researching historical
background but also kind of doing a lot
of the pre design process like having
the right models and just kind of idea
of what would fit best in the space that
you have